oh
these shoes you like them oh do i like
them i love them can i have them yes you
can are you what size are you eight and
a half five okay wow we're screwed oh
we're screwed yeah girl you look
beautiful i'm loving this you're like
i'm gonna show some skin tonight huh
yeah in a classy way darlings classy way
girl it is so good to see you last time
i saw you was that global citizens it's
a very emotional night there oh yeah are
we gonna be crying tonight on the stage
i don't know i don't know what will
happen on that stage i hope all good
things
what can we expect with have mercy
well you can expect me performing my
heart out as usual but i don't know how
it's going to come out tonight
fingers crossed all goes well just
beautiful beings who help me put it
together and i can't wait to see it
finished
this is your ama's debut what does that
mean to you it means everything i
remember when sis and i came in the
audience years ago to the amaze and now
being able to be up here and perform my
single and i just put it out like two
months ago it's crazy and i just can't
wait for more this guy's the limit and
she's here tonight to supporting you
right she's around here beautiful sister
she's coming soon yes i love it now
obviously the last time we talked
we're still no uh release date for the
new album yet right no not yet okay when
is that bad [ __ ] energy coming oh it's
coming it's already here boo i know it's
here but we want the full pack she's
like i'm gonna change the subject right
now we're gonna talk no no no my nails
were like but it matches i know it looks
great
back to the fashion really quick what is
the secret about this look oh the secret
well boob tape boot tape yeah a little
shimmer shine
it's like classic chic and it's really
fun it's simple and you just did a juice
cleanse didn't you oh i did you saw my
tweet i started a month ago i had to get
snatched real quick how did it go i
think it you know the second day was
hell but i made it and i'm here and i'm
eating now yes and yes all of it now how
will you celebrate tonight when the
night's over and your work's done i'm
going to get a cinnabun from cineholic
it's the best vegan cinnabon spot um and
i'm just going to eat a lot and then
work out hard in the morning because i'm
trying to be snatched now
well i'm coming with you i'm gonna put
this mic down i'm coming with you we're
gonna go get some cinnabon boom thank
you okay have so much money
[Music]